hello reject nation Greg Alba here Megan
has a YouTube channel people it's called
the tiny tutor if you're a parent who
needs to learn how to teach their kid to
be a better kid smarter stuff yeah you
know things my mom didn't teach me but
would hit me for not learning you guys
can go to that channel and check out the
tiny tutor some adorable stuff on there
follow her social media I'm telling you
guys it's worth it especially if you're
a parent primarily if you're a parent
sure hey Megan you have seen Nicholas
when in reference movie Drive right
we're in the shirt today
apparently the director has a TV show
for Amazon oh why do I not know about
this okay I just learned about it this
morning well then that's right and you
said that you watch more TV than movies
so I was like dude I need your
television people let's see if we're
gonna add this to our many a queue so
much to stream now I don't know who's in
this I don't know what it's about but
let's find out clean slate
definitely feels like one of his moves
other la Noir
that miles teller it is miles teller is
it yeah yes it is though he's a cop okay
as a very weird trailer
[Music]
[Music]
this show is gonna be crazy whoo
[Music]
what the hell that was really trip it
definitely feels like one of his no it
seems like an LA Noir thrill is this la
it feels like la it has to be the score
is freaking me I mean that's one of the
best things about all the Nicolas women
roughen movies especially Drive was the
choice of music that he uses that
complement the lighting that complement
the entire cinematography is so big on
tone like that slow-moving pace that it
only made sense to have it yeah it
really made sense to have a trailer
where you don't have any dialogue in it
oh my god you're right cuz that's the
kind of movies he makes kind of quiet
films sometimes his characters feel like
avatars in a way of just like watching
people go on some type of weird journey
the story looks like it's gonna be crazy
this movie can get very violent and I'm
wondering how violent is that what
yeah just choking out one guy causing
that woman to regurgitate someone does
it relax or whatever weird trippy stuff
that's also violent and hypnotic I don't
exactly know what this is about but this
definitely feels different like two
pitches a television show and you want
to stand out out of like the thousands
of - you know you have to shoot for
Amazon as they're trying to they're
trying to compete now yeah I have to
they're doing well but like everyone has
to constantly push though totally so
that's what was cool I think like you
said it followed what you expect but
also was unique which is really hard to
do just in the way this trailer was cut
was fascinating because I had footage
but then they also had just stills a lot
of just pictures and then they would
show like photos of the behind the
scenes of it as well yeah and you're
trying to piece it together yeah they're
promoting the production of this which
is a unique approach sometimes shows a
spectrum of the story but they're also
promoting oh no we're putting something
different together we're putting
something special together and miles
tell her to be in a TV show that's free
stuff there's a limit now to who will do
everyone will
it is the new film there's better
performance pieces often to be had and
the TV show cuz there's more exploration
exactly episode after episode season
after season you just get to dig deep
into character and speaking of as an
acting teacher and actor and you should
understand this I love the you know like
when we do dramatic improv in class and
I always say like the silences you don't
feel like they need to just chatter and
talk yeah and then as you said there's
no dialogue you get to just entrench and
character ya much more fascinating I
think that's what he does I have no idea
we were talking about by the way that's
what he does is he does he's like
hypnotic types of filmmaking and I think
putting this in a world that we've all
gravitated towards her for for crime
thrillers is probably the best bet
because he can be a very hit-or-miss
director I think for mainstream
audiences absolutely but but this looks
like the kind of thing we want hi I'm DB
- see there's an actual plot description
here it explores the criminal underbelly
of Los Angeles let's find characters
existential journeys from being killers
to becoming samurais it's that thing
again
yes futuristic when now yeah could it be
tomorrow
what kind of samurais are we targeting
that's the kind of filmmaking he does
though where he can go from like okay I
get it - what the hell's going on yeah
and that's part of why I like it is
always very weird and William Baldwin's
in this - what the hell I'm not gonna
lie there's so much TV out and netflix
produces so much shows amazon's trying
to really jump in on the game they're
getting there they're a lot closer than
they were before there are movies that
this director's done that people have
walked out of because of how violent it
can be heated movie Ryan Gosling called
only God forgives that's kind of hard to
sit through it I've done it there's some
violent moments that are very hard to
sit through and for a TV show for a guy
who embraces violence I'm really
wondering how far he's willing to go
because it's never like fun gore it's
like oh there's like fun gory stuff and
then there's like this feels like real
and disturbing yeah
well like I said I keep pushing the
envelope and it's like how far are we
gonna go guys yeah and then we're just
all desensitized I don't know yeah I
don't know this seems more like my kind
of show honestly and it's cool to see a
like a crime show in LA yes we do enjoy
that feel like most crime shows are not
the LA area so it's cool to gonna la
baie show all right yay to old to die
young recovering what's a cool title too
too old to die young it works it just
makes sense right drama he's gonna be a
part where someone goes up to Mouse
teller and is like you're too young to
die I could write for the show it's all
the same I like to work in titles all
right guys so you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell we actually do full-length TV show
reaction watch alongs on our patreon so
go ahead and check us out over there
more importantly check out Megan's
channel the tiny tutor human beings out
there it's a fun fun channel especially
if you're a parent I know that we got a
lot of parents who watch this channel so
please do us a solid check her out